welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and it's the return of the batch once
again
episode 9 is now out worldwide and in
this video we're going to be breaking
down
all the easter eggs things you missed
and hidden details in the show set in a
galaxy far
far away we're now at the latter end of
the season so it's going to be
interesting to see how things develop
and where the show goes from here
now from this point out it's full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check out the latest episode
then i highly recommend you take an
r2d tour and i'll c-3po you later
what also smash the thumbs up button if
you've been following us for the last
nine weeks
as it's the greatest way to support us
for free and i'll always think
yo the best without the way thank you
for clicking this
no let's get into the bad batch yeah get
away with murder me sometimes anyway the
last episode saw the batch on bracket
and it cad bane showing back up
crosshair getting the anakin treatment
and the batch being left at their lowest
point they'll clearly do whatever they
can to make sure that nobody can lay a
finger on omega
and it's definitely something that's
made them realize they have to fight
back
instead of running interestingly we also
saw that the empire was slowly starting
to take over full production control of
the kaminoans
as an organization they'd pretty much
put their full faith in the fact that
the republic would want to buy soldiers
from them forever
but they didn't account for the war
ending which would of course massively
change things
because they're so reliant on imperial
money they now have to cater to their
every whim
and it's going to be interesting to see
what side they come down on
they really have the opportunity to
either keep playing up to the empire in
order to try and make whatever
money they can from them or they could
make a firm stance and say screw you
guys
don't layer lay a finger on her
that kind that kind of takes us to the
episode
which to me feels far more urgent than
any of the other entries so far
now the entry is called bounty lost
which spoiler alert
is because the big bounty is lost
unfortunately we open with crosshair
chasing the batshit out the skies
attempting to gun them down i was kind
of hoping that he'd need medical care
and that he would be taken to the same
place that the batch had their chips
removed
and from here he would have seen their
procedures and had his taken out which
would have made him see the error of his
ways sadly that's my fan fiction for the
rest of time
and i've given up hope that that's ever
gonna happen now they make their way off
planet with wreckers sitting in the
background turret
similar to a new hope they make the jump
to light speed realizing that cad bane
is long gone
and we cut to his ship to see a mega
trap behind a red force field
that seems very similar to the barriers
in the phantom menace
baines dropped her off in his prison and
he gives an
introduction whilst his little bot toto
360 hops along holding his leg
after having it blown off in the
shootout last week we get it confirmed
that the cameron owens were the one who
hired him
and they agreed to meet at the
rendezvous point with unmarked credits
bane is of course an outlaw and the
imperials are slowly starting to seize
currency
lock the borders down and put a tight
grip around the population
so that they can't step out of line over
the years in the expanded lore
we even learned that palpatine had
somewhat influenced the stormtroopers
and the imperials
and that they all did evil things
because he was emanating the dark side
throughout the entire galaxy
now it was thought that the
stormtroopers who resisted the first
order were actually force sensitive
and though none of this has ever been
confirmed it's just been stuff i've read
there have been several interviews
discussing a lot of elements like this
thus bane wanting to stay out of the
empire's way as an
outlaw makes sense and i like that they
dropped the unmarked credits line here
now there's clearly some back and forth
between the kaminoans with some seeing
her as just being an object
whilst the others see her as a valuable
life form much like grogu the cloners
want her genetic material
and it's revealed that she's very very
special now so far she hasn't exhibited
any force powers per se
and after what we learned in this
episode i kind of feel like that's just
becoming a fan theory that probably
won't come true
tuan way is sent tuan her way to borah
vero to meet bane
and on the ship omega offers to fix
toto's little leg
at first he doesn't want to do it but
eventually he comes around
and she escapes now back with the batch
they go through the files on bane
and pull up the time that he tried to
abduct palpatine there was even an
episode in the clone wars where he took
control of the senate in order to free a
hud prisoner
he's not in the main saga and no one
cared who he was until he put on the hat
but bane is a great character and i'm so
glad he's in the show
after analyzing omega's genetic profile
tech realizes that she has first
generation dna
so get rid of those palpatine clone
theories right now
and she's more like the female version
of boba fett
technically she might even be classed as
his sister and this shows the value that
she has
we learned that boba was called the
alpha and this also explains the alpha
and omega words that have been used to
describe them
since django died the clones have been
reusing the same strain of his genetics
but over time this has diluted the batch
themselves were created
because the kaminoans were forced to do
alternate strands
in order to see if there were better
ways to use what they had left
boba's disappearance has pushed things
to mean that they pretty much have to
get her
in order to be able to start the clone
process again django was obviously
very resourceful and we see this
mirrored in omega who manages to get her
way out of the cell
by tricking toto cut to borovio and we
see a very similar setup to the mining
stations that were present in the empire
strikes back
there's also mention of the door handles
being similar to the ones into poker
city which in case you don't know is
actually the name of the city of the
cloners
now these platforms look very similar
the ones at the poker so i think we can
assume they're simply floating versions
of them
due to the doors and what we later learn
the camera owens clearly have several
operations like this throughout the
galaxy
and who knows we might even discover
more as the show goes on
omega tries to send a transmission to
the batch and though she makes it
through
bane catches her before she can fully
let them know what planet she's on
things take a turn though when tuan way
is found dead at the location
and it's revealed that fenix shan killed
her for the payment
turns out that shan is working for the
kamino and that wants her brought in
safely
and it's clear that she's gonna cause a
lot of disputes amongst the race
now it breaks out into a shootout and i
love when shan kicks the thermal
detonator
this loses the credits but the fight
doesn't stop
and omega does a little hop through a
slightly open door
similar to han on the death star a big
twist comes when omega encounters
cloning vats at the location
and what looks like the cameron owens
inside it it would be pretty crazy if we
learned that the cloners were so good at
carrying out the procedures
because their entire species is based
around duplicating each other
this would mean that we might even see
tuan wei again
and who knows they may all have chips in
their heads and be completely loyal to
the prime minister
when he wants them to be outside shandon
fennick come face to face
and bane lifts up his hat to reveal that
he has a metal plate over his head
bait never had this before in the clone
wars and they clearly bring focus to it
for a reason
this could actually mean that he may
have already had his fatal showdown with
bet
and survived it i'm not 100 sure on that
but just looking at the way it happens
it also makes a lot of sense omega
climbs down to a flight pod
but toto stalks her on the ladder and i
got a lot of annie vibes from this
she jumps on him to get down there
quickly whilst shannon bane battled out
bane wins but it's too late and the
bounty's lost
now bane whips out the double
flamethrower but shan
bowles him and kicks him off the edge
which forces the character to use his
jetpack boots
unfortunately omega's ship starts going
haywire
but she's saved by the batch who pull
her through the cargo shoot
similar to what luke was pulled through
in the empire strikes back
omega is devastated that she's being
hunted and honda breaks it to her that
she's so valuable because of her dna
strand
we discover that shan shafted bane's
ship and that she may be hiding future
in order to protect omega as long as
omega is safe though that's all that
matters
and after coming face to face with the
owens in the tank
she realizes she doesn't want that life
hunter makes a promise that he will
protect her no matter what
and i actually think we might be getting
some more bounty hunters popping up in
the show at some point
give us bosk and i'll be happy well that
ends the episode on a really high note
now as for my thoughts on the series i
really feel like they're taking things
in directions that i wasn't expecting
i know over the months i've talked about
how this show is very much about
conformity versus independence
but i also feel that it has other themes
going on in it such as what it means to
be human
versus what it means to be used as a
machine star wars to me has always been
about the rise and fall of darth vader
a man that ended up becoming a twisted
emotionless machine that carried out
orders without question
however luke managed to bring him back
around and remind him of what it meant
to be human
this is something that is layered
throughout the saga and it's sort of
like poetry
i mean i mean it doesn't rhyme or
anything but it just
does the same things over and over again
can we come up with a better way to say
that anyway luke's journey itself was
about him following in his father's
footsteps
and it was clear that he should avoid
his mistakes and keep his humanity
which was of course helped by his sister
and his friends
this idea of what it means to be human
and the pitfalls that come when you lose
it is something that has popped up
several times throughout the saga
making for all to be really well
connected now the bad batteries i'm not
going to say it's all connected now the
bad batch was simply soldiers
that followed orders and they didn't
really feel anything or make their own
choices however that has changed
and just in the same way that they were
teaching omega how to fight and be a
soldier
she has taught the bad batch what it
means to be human that's why it was so
crushing when she was taken away
and she's definitely the most important
character in my opinion
i think the batch hunter especially
really saw her as a ray of light
and when you look at all these elements
it's kind of crazy to be getting this in
a show that many just see as a cartoon
that's why i really really enjoy it i
think it's probably the best direction
that they could have taken the clone
wars after the show came to an end
i always wondered how things would go
when they shifted the focus from the
jedi to the clone troopers
and though there were episodes in the
series that did this i didn't think they
would carry the character complexities
that this show has
so far i really enjoyed the show overall
this episode was another great addition
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the bad batch its themes
and what you think will happen next time
comment below and let me know and as a
thank you for interacting with the video
you'll be entered into a prize draw on
the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
at heavyspoilers if you want somebody
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of loki
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you enjoy that show too
now without the way thank you for
sitting through the video i've been paul
i'll see you next time
take care peace